this crater in the French countryside
was left by the first explosion of the
Battle of the Somme we brought together
two men whose families are linked to it
forever their grandfathers were both
killed on the first day the Lord
Saratoga the battle of the somme which
began on July the first 1916 was one of
the bloodiest in human history more than
half a million british soldiers were
amassed to attack the German trenches on
the Western Front in France they thought
it was the final push to end the war but
20,000 died in just a few hours paddy
Butler has always known his grandfather
died a hero trying to rescue his
commanding officer Patrick Butler was a
sergeant in the first Tyneside Irish one
of the Powell's battalions of volunteers
who answered kitchener's call to arms he
returned from France on leave shortly
before the Battle his son Patty's father
was seven he told me that he was in the
kitchen when and present when his dad
said to his mother were going back out
there now and give the wedding ring
Dewey's wife and his watch and said we
won't be coming back that same week 300
miles away Sergeant Butler's commanding
officer leftenant Colonel Louis Howard
was also at home on leave to see his
baby son it's sort of slightly out of
the camera shot his grandchildren are
now old enough to be retired his
daughter-in-law is 97 he came home on
leave and bill was three months old and
then when his leave was over he went
back to the front and that was the last
time she ever saw him
within a few weeks of returning to
France both men were dead Patrick Butler
was shot trying to rescue the fatally
wounded Louis Howard from no man's land
on the first day of the battle what is
it mean to the Irish a Centurion the
Howards and the butler's came together
again at the National Archives in queue
to see the war diary for that day these
were completed by any unit operational
service and effectively to the
blow-by-blow account morning taking
zahir written by a soldier in pencil as
the battle raged it describes the
opening minutes first of the 716 740
a.m. the battalion on the left tenant
Colonel LM Howard left the assembly
tranches his third wave in the attack on
leaving the trenches the enemy opened
intense machine-gun fire doing heavy
damage to our troops battalion objective
was not gained so much assistance be
needed for the battalions in front the
following officers were killed or
injured left-tenant colonel LM Howard
the two men died at the Loch nagar
crater more than 20 tons of explosives
were set off under the German front line
at 728 am marking the start of the
British attack the religious world why
sellers which means a day that was
completely destroyed across the valley
the soldiers of the Tyneside Irish
watched the detonation from their
trenches battle field guides David and
Julie Thompson outlined the daunting
task that faced them that morning the
critical minutes it takes the first wave
to move forward the Germans have retaken
the land around the crater critically
taken the rim of the crater and are now
using that and as observation and
sniping positions looking straight into
the oncoming 34th division moving ahead
of us the Germans had all the best
positions and had
survived days of shelling some of the
Tyneside Irish reached the crater but
six out of ten were dead or injured a
commanding officer was one of them my
grandfather was course on barbed wire
essentially in no man's land roughly
where would he have been in the i would
i would suggest here he is probably 20
meters from where we see the crater
today bear in mind the german frontline
being the roadway running from the
crater to the bottom of the village yeah
we will have but german bar doire
entanglements dotted across that line
the crater itself is now preserved as a
memorial paddy Butler has been here
before to see where his grandfather died
trying to save Colonel Howard I mean
when you looked at it shares in it for
Malcolm it's the first time when you
think 100 years ago and here we are
standing here now looking at the spot
where grandfather's died crowler all the
stories we hear the Germans were over
there the advance was coming this way
and yet this was seen as a some sort of
point of refuge amidst all the mayhem
there was refuge that are safety to be
found if you can get to the crater and
yet it seems to that was quite the
reverse of the truth both men are buried
within sight of where they fell in a
cemetery in between the two front lines
Colonel Howard led 980 men into battle
that day by nightfall 650 of them were
killed or injured seems very close
standing here surrounded by so many who
have not named
so many the stones just say a soldier of
the Great War 100 years ago the families
met and after 100 years they meet again
it's it's unique and special I think
have we learned anything at 100 years
doing no nother thing still fighting
still killer now we'll still go on
killing and fighting we're the world is
the Battle of the Somme lasted until
November pushing the British frontline
to the ridge beyond the crater and
weakening the German army on the Western
Front the cost in lives between the two
sides was almost a million men
Toronto Sky News the song